there steve kaufman here today i want to
tell you
the secret of how i learn languages
that's the subject of my discussion
today
people often say to me uh you know steve
you've obviously got a talent for
languages
you've learned so many languages you
know good for you but i could never do
it
and i often say to myself at least well
why don't you try doing it the way i do
it
maybe
it's also a matter of the method that i
use
and so i want to tell you exactly now
because it's really quite simple
the secret to how i learn languages to
me
learning languages is is essentially
the
i would summarize it this way it's the
relentless pursuit of words
words that i glean
through content that is of interest to
me that's basically what it boils down
to uh if i look at the languages that i
have learned french in a way doesn't
count because i had it at school and
then i studied it at mcgill and then i
went to france where i studied
in french at the institute politik and
so i was you know eventually was
immersed in it as i say in my book i
really couldn't speak much in french but
once i got turned on to french it wasn't
difficult in montreal and subsequently
in france to achieve quite a high level
the significance with french is that it
made me confident that i could learn but
in chinese i remember
when i was in hong kong i would scour
the bookstores
looking for material that had these
glossaries like readers
readers on chinese literature politics
history anything i could find any book
that anybody put out that had
some kind of content with a glossary so
i wouldn't have to use the dictionary i
would buy them and and that i didn't
just use the textbook that they had at
my chinese language school and so i was
on chinese for nine months and and
that's but essentially i between that
and listening a lot that's how i learned
and and i as i have said many times i
ignored the grammatical explanations and
just got used to the patterns
in japanese i had to learn it on my own
and there again i would just scour the
bookstores for as much material as i
could find
so this whole idea that that language
learning is a matter of pursuing words
okay it's it's just that's very simple